[Musik]
Recep Tayyip Erdogan war in den letzten
20 Jahren Herr und Meister der
türkischen Politik und jetzt hat er zum
Leidwesen fast der gesamten westlichen
Welt erneut die Wahlen gewonnen nachdem
er einen obskuren und skurrilen Putsch
überlebt Verfassungsänderungen nach
Gutsherrenart durchgeboxt und eine
bizarre Wirtschaftspolitik implementiert
hat die dem Land schwer zusetzt und den
Wert der Lehrer zerstörte setzen die
Türken immer noch auf Erdogan unter
seiner Führung hat sich die Türkei von
einer toleranten islamischen Demokratie
und einem Beispiel für Mäßigung zu einem
zunehmend unbequemen Partner für die
Europäische Union und die NATO
entwickelt viele sind sogar der Meinung
das wäre an der Schwelle zu einer neuen
großen Autokratie direkt vor den Toren
Europas stehen für andere sind wir
Zeugen des endgültigen Bruch der Türkei
mit dem besten und seinen Werten immer
entsprechend die hier von einem
Kandidaten der selbst am Wahltag noch an
den Türen seines Wahllokals Geldbündel
verteilt hat er glaubt mir nicht dann
sitzt euch doch selbst an aber wie sind
wir eigentlich bis hierher gekommen und
was bedeutet das alles wie ist dieser
türkische neosultan überhaupt entstanden
worauf hat er es wirklich abgesehen
warum hat er es trotz seiner vielen
fails geschafft die letzte Wahl zu
gewinnen heute dann bei all diese Fragen
natürlich beantworten um dies jedoch
auch qualifiziert tun zu können müssen
wir uns erst einmal Überblick über die
Gesamtsituation verschaffen also
aufgepasst der Sponsor unseres heutigen
Videos ist übrigens ein Unternehmen das
mehr ganz besonders am Herzen liegt und
zwar nicht nur wegen seiner tollen
Produkte sondern auch bei ihm
seinerseits unsere Umwelt Tiere und
Kinder am Herzen liegen Holzkern hat
nach 20 Jahren meine Begeisterung für
Ohren wieder zum Leben erweckt ja es
stimmt während meiner Schulzeit konnte
ich mir nicht vorstellen ohne Uhr am
Handgelenk außer Haus zu gehen aber dann
bin ich doch zu ohrenmuffel geworden die
Uhrzeit kann man ja am Handy ablesen und
irgendwie hatten die damalige uhrenmode
auch nicht zugesagt dann bin ich jedoch
auf Holzkern gestoßen und naja sieht sie
euch einfach mal an ich bin der Meinung
dass dieses Korrektur verbundene Design
dieser kernige Charakter einfach zu mir
passen oder was meint ihr und ganz
bestimmt findest auch du immer riesigen
Sortiment von Holzkern das passende
Modell für dich schon beim Auspacken des
natürlich versandkostenfreien Päckchens
merkt man dass sich die österreichische
Firma Holzkern ganz besondere Mühe gibt
das wirklich jede Facette eures
uhrenerlebnis ist perfekt und
gleichzeitig herrlicher natürlich ist
und dann fallen eine natürlich die
eigentlichen Materialien auf aus denen
die Uhr gefertigt ist ihre Maserung
Marmorierung und das schildern von Holz
Stein und Perlmutt jedes Stück ist von
Natur aus ein Unikat die Natur
Verbundenheit von Holz ganz zeigt sich
jedoch nicht nur in ihren Produkten
sondern auch darin dass ihre Herstellung
Verpackung und die Lieferketten so
nachhaltig wie möglich gehalten sind
aber sogar darüber hinaus wer weiß die
österreichische Firma dass sie ein
großes Herz hat konkret unterstützt
trotzdem drei wichtige Projekte die
wieder Auffassung der Wälder im szenegal
durch das Institut keine für Tiere in
Bukarest und zusammen mit Österreich
humanitärisches Projekte für Kinder in
Bangladesch und dabei handelt es sich
nicht um welches symbolprojekte im
Senegal zum Beispiel werden 40.000
baumsämlinge gepflanzt und
brandschutzzonen und Workshops
organisiert und der Lebensraum der
Schimpansen wieder hergestellt Gut
Aiderbichl hilft Straßenhunden in
Bukarest mit einem Tierheim das
medizinische Versorgung Kastrationen und
Vermittlung anbietet über 600 Tiere
wurden so bereits gerettet und
vermittelt in nordbangler der
schwiegerung wird die Unterernährung bei
Kindern bekämpft durch lokale
Lebensmittelsicherheit und Bildung der
Entwicklung einer Online
ernährungsplattform oder Etablierung von
Schulgärten und Selbsthilfegruppen und
das alles wird wie folgt finanziert wenn
du bei deiner Bestellung den
rabattcodepolitik einträgst bekommst du
10% Rabatt und darüber hinaus gehen
weitere fünf Prozent an die eben
erwähnten Projekte die Mittel werden
dabei gleichmäßig verteilt die Aktion
ist bis zum 16 Juni aktiv also lasst
euch diese Gelegenheit nicht entgehen
tut euch etwas Gutes und helft dabei
gleichzeitig auch anderen Gedanken euch
übrigens könnt ihr auch unsere Arbeit
direkt unterstützen durch eine
freiwillige Spende über den Link den
sich ebenfalls in die Beschreibung
gepackt haben auf dass ihr euch in
Zukunft noch mit viel informativen
Videos wie diesen beglücken können so
und wenn ihr das erledigt habt lasst uns
an den Bosporus aufbrechen und die Lage
dort genau unter die Lupe nehmen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das Osmanische Reich beteiligte sich als
Verbündeter Deutschlands Österreich
Ungarns und Bulgariens am Ersten
Weltkrieg dies sollte die letzte große
Aktion dieses Reiches sein zumindest
unter dieser Bezeichnung denn 1918
standen sie auf der Verliererseite so
dass die siegreichen Alliierten den
damaligen Sultan mehm mit den sechsten
zwingen konnten den Vertrag von silvrest
zu unterzeichnen dieser Vertrag
bestätigte die Kapitulation des
Osmanischen Reiches und bedeutet die
Aufteilung seiner Territorien außerhalb
der Türkei er sah auch die
internationale Kontrolle der Stadt
Istanbul der mehr enger am Bosporus und
der Dardanellen vor außerdem die
Schaffung einer großen neuen
unabhängigen armenischen Nationen in Ost
Anatolien und einer Pufferzone für die
Kurden diese sollten sich nach einer
Zeit der Autonomie für die
Unabhängigkeit entscheiden können
allerdings wurde dieser Vertrag aufgrund
des türkischen Widerstands oder der
Führung von Mustafa Kemal Atatürk der
den sogenannten türkischen
Unabhängigkeitskrieg führte von der
osmanischen Regierung nie ratifiziert
infolge dieses Krieges wurde der Vertrag
von zellfreien 1923 durch den Vertrag
von Lausanne ersetzt dieser setzte die
modernen Grenzen der Republik Türkei
fest und hob viele der Bestimmung des
Vertrags von silvrett auf tja und dann
kam der zweite Weltkrieg und da zeigte
sich bereits eindeutiges Zeichen für das
was von da an das Doppelte Gesichter
türkischen Außenpolitik werden sollte
denn obwohl das Land 1939 ein
Schutzabkommen mit Frankreich und den
Vereinigten Königreich unterzeichnet
hatte veranlasten die Erfolge des
deutschen blitzkriegs Ankara um 1941
dazu auch einen Freundschaftsvertrag mit
dem Dritten Reich zu unterzeichnen das
Ergebnis die türkischen Streitkräfte
wurden sowohl mit der Technologie der
Alliierten als auch der Achsenmächte
ausgerüstet erst 1945 als der Krieg
eigentlich schon klar entschieden war
sind die Türken dann definitiv zu den
Alliierten übergelaufen nun ja damit
bewiesen sie wieder eine mutigen noch
eine loyale Haltung aber sie hatten
Glück denn mit Beginn des Kalten Krieges
war dieses ganze hin und her über Nacht
vergessen
der Wettbewerb mit den Sowjets
veranlasste das Weiße Haus dazu einen
umfassenden sicherheitsvertrag mit der
Türkei zu unterzeichnen der seit 1947 zu
umfangreicher Militärhilfe führt
[Musik]
so entstand die besondere Beziehung
zwischen Washington und Ankara und damit
auch die Beziehung der Türkei zur
gesamten westlichen Welt auf diese Weise
besiegelte die türkische Regierung ihre
Integration in den Westen und traten
1949 den Europarat 52 der Nation 61 der
oicid bei die Türkei blieb jedoch ein
Land voller Spannungen die Stationierung
von us-peter Atomraketen auf ihrem
Territorium die direkt auf die
Sowjetunion gerichtet waren rückte das
Land ihres gesamten Kalten Krieges in
den Brennpunkt der politischen Debatte
auf der einen Seite versuchten viele
türkische Politiker intern nach und nach
ein viel religiöseres Modell für das
Land durchzusetzen dies wurde nur durch
den Druck der Streitkräfte aufgehalten
Jahrzehnte lang war die türkische Armee
so etwas wie ein Schutzschild gegen die
zunehmende Islamisierung des Landes doch
auch dieser Mechanismus funktioniert
nicht immer auf die wünschenswerteste
Weise die Rede ist von zwei
Staatsstreichen einem 1960 und dem
anderen 1980
und das ist noch nicht alles
jahrzehntelang war das Land auch in ein
großes Tauziehen zwischen
zentralstaatlicher Planung und
marktkapitalismus verwickelt zwischen
dem Ende des Zweiten Weltkriegs und den
80er Jahren herrschen im wesentlichen
eine Planungspolitik und die Kontrolle
der Wirtschaft durch den Staat vor das
gleiche gilt für den Protektionismus zur
angeblichen Unterstützung der heimischen
Industrie erst ab den 80er Jahren wandte
sich das Land dem freien Markt und dem
Kapitalismus zu
und an dieser Stelle meine Lieben
Zuschauer besteht kein Zweifel die
geographische Lage der Türkei als
Knotenpunkt zwischen Asien Europa und
den Namen Osten war für diesen ganzen
Prozess absolut entscheidend aus diesem
Grund versuchten westliche Institutionen
die Türkei mehr und mehr zu integrieren
eine Zeit lang schien das Land sogar
kurz davor zu stehen der Europäischen
Union beizutreten und das war im Grunde
das Land in dem Rezept Erdogan aufwuchs
sich entwickelte und empor steht ein
Land auf halbweg zwischen Ost und West
zwischen Säkularisierung und Laizismus
zwischen Kapitalismus und Planwirtschaft
ja und so war es auch bis Erdogan selbst
an die Macht kam der Mann der das Land
in den ersten beiden Jahrzehnten des 21
Jahrhundert prägte aufgepasst
Fußball Islam und militärischer Druck
im Mai 1971 stellten die türkischen
Streitkräfte ein Ultimatum an die
konservative Regierung von Süleyman
Demirel und generelle alle politischen
Parteien das Militär forderte von den
Politikern den wachsenden religiösen
Extremismus einzudämmen für die
republikanische Ordnung ins Chaos
stürzte diese Situation verschlechterte
sich noch nach dem Ausbruch einer
schweren Wirtschaftskrise die zum großen
Teil durch den starken
handelsproduktionismus verursacht wurde
tatsache ist dass diese Krise zu einer
hohen Arbeitslosigkeit über 20% und eine
außer Kontrolle geratenen Inflation
führte während die jährliche Inflation
1972 beispielsweise
14,4%, 80 bereits über 94% daraufhin
ordnete die Regierung das Verbot mehrere
Parteien eine Parteien die gegen die
sekularisierung waren das heißt gegen
das Modell des Konfessionslosen Staates
zu diesen verbotenen Gruppierungen
gehört auch die nationale Ordnungspartei
MLP in der Erdogan ein Aktivist war im
Jahr darauf gründete der Vorsitzende
dieser Partei nicht mit den Erbach kann
eine weitere ähnliche Gruppierung unter
dem Namen nat nationale rettungspartei
Kurs MSP merkt euch diesen Namen denn er
wird für die Zukunft des noch jungen
ratchef entscheidend sein die
turbulenten 1970er Jahre endeten
schließlich mit einem Staatsstreich im
Jahr 1980 in jenem Jahr setzte die
Militär unter der Führung von General
Kennern Evern die demokratischen
Institutionen außer Kraft sie weitete
das Kriegsrecht ausverbot alle
politischen Parteien und inhaftierte und
verurteilte 10 tausende politische
Aktivisten und während dieser Zeit in
der die Politik fest im Griff der
Militärs war erkundete Erdogan Liebe
andere Bereiche er versuchte sich z.B
als professionelle Fußballspieler und
schaffte es eine Universitätsabschluss
in Betriebswirtschaft zu erwerben
[Applaus]
tatsache ist das 1983 unter dem
Deckmantel der neuen freizügigen
Gesetzgebung des Militärs die nationale
heilpartei in die Wohlfahrtspartei
umgewandelt wurde und Erdogan unter dem
Kommando von Erba kam wieder ins
politische Leben zurückspringen und
seine große Durchbruch sollte
1984 kommen in diesem Jahr kehrte eine
demokratisch gewählte Regierung an die
Macht zurück und genau dann begann
Erdogan politischen Einfluss in der
Opposition zu gewinnen er wurde zum
Koordinator der Wohlfahrtspartei in der
Provinz istanbulan ernannt nach und nach
wurde sein Name immer bekannter er
repräsentierte die einzige islamistische
Kraft mit Einfluss in den städtischen
Bezirken des Landes
und so wurde erdo an 1994 mit 25,2% der
Stimme zum neuen Bürgermeister Istanbuls
gewählt merkt euch auch diesen Moment er
war ein entscheidender Wendepunkt denn
eine islamistische Partei hatte die
Kontrolle über die wichtigste Stadt der
ganzen Türkei übernommen und die Frage
die sich das ganze Land stellte war wie
würde dieser Magistrat diese neue
Stadtregierung aussehen würden die
Islamisten den Säkularismus ein Ende
setzen könnten sie am Ende einen neuen
Staatsstreich provozieren nun ja die
Wahrheit ist das Erdogan wusste wie er
seine Karten ausspielen konnte es war
die perfekte Gelegenheit um zu zeigen
dass seine islamistische Partei eine
Kraft der Mehrheiten sein kann
zur Überraschung vieler gab der
Bürgermeister dem Management und der
Technokratie den Vorzug vor der Religion
so förderte er zum Beispiel einen Plan
für öffentliche Arbeiten und
neutechnologien um die Probleme der
Wasserversorgung des überlasteten
Straßennetzes und des abfallsystems zu
lösen Infrastruktur und öffentliche
Dienstleistungen waren eindeutig sein
Markenzeichen und sein Sprungbrett in
die nationale Politik plötzlich schien
die Wohlfahrtspartei ihrer islamistische
Agenda beiseite zu schieben um zum
Bannerträger der Modernisierung in den
Städten zu werden und wisst ihr was dank
dieser Entwicklung wollte sie 1995 bei
den Parlamentswahlen die stärkste Kraft
auf nationale Ebene noch waren sie doch
nicht in der Lage eine Regierung zu
bilden das Militär stellte sich ihnen
frontal entgegen und forderte die beiden
anderen großen politischen Parteien die
mutterleibspartei und die Partei des
wahren Weges auf einen regierungspark zu
schließen diese große Koalition sollte
ein Veto gegen die Islamisten darstellen
denn ob moderat oder nicht das Militär
wollte nicht riskieren dass sie auch nur
im geringsten in der nationalen Politik
vertreten sind diese große Koalition
gegen die Islamisten hielt jedoch kaum
ein Jahr und am 28 Juni 1996 gelang es
matchmädchen aber kann den Gründer der
einzigen großen islamistischen
politischen Kraft des Landes
Ministerpräsident zu werden und nein
glaubt nicht dass er Erdogans legt
Ermäßigung folgte
wollte eine viel islamistischere Agenda
vorantreiben zu seinen Hauptpunkten
gehörte die Annäherung an Länder wie
Libyen oder den Iran und das war dann
doch zu viel für das Militär das den
1997 zum Rücktritt waren nur kurz darauf
Verbotes Verfassungsgericht der Türkei
die Wohlfahrtspartei selbst wegen
Aktivitäten die gegen den Laizismus des
Staates gerichtet sind aber das war noch
nicht alles auch Erdogan selbst wurde
von den Justizbehörden wegen
Aufstachelung zum religiösen Hass
verurteilt konkret wurde ihm vorgeworfen
die Folgen des Dichters und
nationalistischen Ideologen sie ja gut
kalt bei einer politischen Kundgebung
als Proklamation verwendet zu haben
nehmt euch jetzt in acht denn er nimmt
wahrlich keinen Blatt vor dem Mund es
handelt es sich wirklich um eine klare
Manifestation seiner Absicht die
Moscheen sind unsere Kasernen die
Kuppeln unsere Helme die Minarette
unsere bayonette und die Gläubigen
unserer Soldaten Erdogan wurde aus dem
Amt des Bürgermeisters entlassen und zu
10 Monaten Gefängnis verurteilt aber
Moment mal werdet ihr euch jetzt fragen
Vorurteil weit wegen des Rezitierens
einiger Verse nun wir haben euch ja
bereits gesagt dass die Religionsfrage
ein sehr sensibles Thema in der Türkei
war und eigentlich hätten wir damals
alle denken können dass Erdogans
politische Karriere nach seinem
Amtsenthebungsverfahren und seiner
Inhaftierung zu Ende sein würde aber wie
wir alle wissen hat ja zum Beispiel auch
Hitlers Festungshaft erst seinen
Heldenstatus gefestigt und das war auch
bei Erdogan der Fall die Frage lautet
Wasser eigentlich getan hat um sich
wieder zu etablieren um an die Macht zu
kommen und so große Mehrheiten zu
gewinnen nun genau das werden wir uns
jetzt ansehen
[Musik]
als Erdogan seine Freiheit wieder
erlangte wurde er vollständig aus dem
politischen Leben verbannt es gab keine
Möglichkeit für ihn zu kandidieren oder
eine politische Partei zu gründen die
Frage war allerdings ob es wirklich
nötig hatte eine eindeutig islamistische
Rolle einzunehmen oder ob er diese
Angelegenheit erst mal beiseite schieben
und versuchen sollte irgendwie auf die
politische Bühne zurückzukehren nun ja
meine Lieben Zuschauer Erdogan wurde
ziemlich bald klar dass er einfach jede
Gelegenheit ergreifen musste die sich im
Boot seine oberste Priorität musste sein
seine öffentliche Position
wiederherzustellen denn immerhin war
seine Rolle als meisterhafter Stadt
Manager Istanbuls noch immer im
Gedächtnis der Menschen und so gründete
Erdogan im Jahr 2001 als das verboten
seine politischen Aktivitäten aufgehoben
wurde die Partei für Gerechtigkeit und
Entwicklung seine politische Speerspitze
uns ist sie heutzutage unter den Kürzel
AKP bekannt damals handelt es sich um
eine politische Maschine die zum
bestmöglichen Zeitpunkt kam denn zu
Beginn des 21 und als war die Türkei ein
Land in der Krise in den Nachrichten wie
die folgende regierten 25 Februar 2001
die Türkei in Aufruhr angesichts einer
Finanzkrise die den Aktienmarkt
abstürzen und die Zinssätze in die Höhe
schnellen ließ sah sich die Türkei
gezwungen die Bemühungen um die
Aufrechterhaltung des Wertes ihrer
Währung der Lira aufzugeben die
durchschnittliche jährliche Inflation
lag bei rund 60%, die Arbeitslosenquote
explodierte und der Bär der Lehrer war
stark gesunken es waren die große Chance
auf die unser Protagonist gewartet hatte
seinen Moment war gekommen die religiöse
Agenda hatte keine Priorität er musste
sich als effizienter Manager
präsentieren und sich auf seine
pragmatische Zeit als Bürgermeister von
Istanbul beziehen der Hintergedanke das
alles würde ihm in einer wirtschaftlich
schwierigen Zeit sozialen Rückhalt geben
und auch die Bedenken des Militärs
besänftigen und das Ergebnis nun ja seht
euch an
die Parteienlandschaft war nach den
Wahlen derart zersplittert dass Erdogans
Partei mit nur
34,28% der Stimmen eine überwältigende
absolute Mehrheit errangt seine
Versprechen dermäßigung oder Annäherung
an die Europäische Union brachten in die
Zustimmung des Militärs ein keiner würde
sich ihn in den Weg stellen oder würde
sein Wort halten seine islamistische
Agenda wurde erstmal auf Eis gelegt denn
um die wirklich großen umweltenden Ziele
zu verwirklichen muss man auf den
richtigen Moment warten und hierzu sind
enorme Mengen angeduld notwendig Geduld
die erdogan hatte und so setzte er
zunächst eine Reformpaket durch das die
Privatisierung von Staatsbetrieben
beschleunigen und Handels und Finanzen
abbauen sollte in Folge dessen stiegen
die auslandsinvestitionsprunghaft an und
die Türkei erlebte einen Wirtschaftsbuch
und wie wir beide Politik oft sagen gibt
es Zeiten in denen ein Bild mehr sagt
als tausend Worte und dies ist genau
einer dieser Fälle setzt euch an
[Musik]
nachdem er du an dem März 2003 an die
Macht gekommen war stiegen die
auslandsinvestitionsprunghaft an die
eingeleiteten Maßnahmen brachten die
Inflation nennen einen einstelligen
Bereich zurück und die Wirtschaft des
Landes erlebt einen wahrhaften Höhenflug
Mann nannte dies das türkische Wunder
[Musik]
und dank dieser Erfolge nahm Erdogan als
politischer Führer immer mehr und mehr
Menschen für sich ein seine Macht wuchs
und wuchs das ging dann so weit dass er
irgendwann stark genug wurde um auch
seine islamistische Agenda wieder
hervorzuholen darüber haben wir schon
mehreren anderen Videos berichtet die
wir euch in der Beschreibung verlinken
werden fakt ist Erdogan war an einem
Punkt angekommen in dem sich ihm kaum
einer widersetzen konnte er wusste eine
überwältigende gesellschaftliche
Mehrheit hinter sich war für das
sogenannte türkische Wunder
verantwortlich und hatte nach und nach
Führungsposition in allen staatlichen
Institutionen mit seinen erfolgsleuten
besetzt auch in der Armee ja allerdings
nicht in der gesamten Armee aufgepasst
[Musik]
ein Leopard wechselt nicht seine Flecken
der Wechsel des politischen Tons den
Erdogan inszenierte um an die Macht zu
kommen war er instrumentell er endete
nichts an seinen tiefsten politischen
Überzeugungen dem Islamismus und einer
sehr autoritären Auffassung von Politik
zum Beispiel demonstrierte 2013 eine
Gruppe von Umweltschützern gegen den
Abriss eines Parks in der Stadt Istanbul
obwohl es sich nicht um einen groß
angelegten Protest gegen die Regierung
handelte empörte die skrupellose
Unterdrückung der Demonstranten die
türkische Gesellschaft und die gesamte
Opposition diese nutzte die Gelegenheit
dann um für größere Proteste zu werden
die Proteste fanden zwischen Mai und
Juni derselben Jahres statt und endeten
mit Dutzenden von Verletzten zahlreichen
verhafteten Journalisten und starken
Drohungen gegen die Medien und nicht nur
das in dieser Zeit versuchte die
Regierung Erdogan auf verschiedene Weise
das Internet zu zensieren zum Beispiel
scheinte sie die Nutzung von Twitter ein
26 Juni 2014 internetsensor in der
Türkei seit die Proteste auf dem
taxiplatz im Sommer 2013 begann
türkische Regierung verstärkt mit Gewalt
gegen sie vor ein neues Gesetz
ermöglicht es ihr für Sie unbequeme
Blogs und Twitter-Konten zu schließen
ebenso baute Erdogan die Institutionen
des Staates schrittweise nach seinen
Vorstellungen um es handelte sich um
eine rigorose Gleichschaltung aber
scheibchenweise seit 2010 begann Erdogan
nahestehende Staatsanwälte eine Kampagne
von Verhaftung und verhören gegen
hochrangige Offiziere der Streitkräfte
der Druck war so groß geworden das ist
am 15 juli 2016 zu einem Putschversuch
kam
für viele war ein Zeichen der
überdrüssigkeit des Militärs für andere
ein von Erdogan selbstorganisierter
Putschversuch um endgültig aufzuräumen
was auf jeden Fall klar ist ist das
Endergebnis 194 Toto und mehr als 1100
verletzte die Putschisten scheiterten
und Erdogan als politischer Führer
übernahm die totale Kontrolle sagen wir
einfach dass der Putsch ihn die
Möglichkeit gab die Armee von oben bis
unten zu erneuern ohne das Gegengewicht
der Armee setzte Erdogan 2017 dann eine
Verfassungsreform durch diese machte ihn
dann zu einem umfassenden Herrscher der
das Parlament auflösen und sogar die
Hälfte der Verfassungsrichter nennen
kann seitdem befinden sich alle
freiheitsindikatoren der Türkei im
freien Fall die Verfolgung politischer
Gegner ist an der Tagesordnung die
Medien sind gezähmt wenn sie nicht sogar
vom Staat in den meisten Fällen
gesteuert werden das Beschneiden von
Freiheiten hat aber seine Konsequenzen
von da an begann die ausländischen
Investitionen zu sinken und was war
Erdogans Reaktion darauf nun er brachte
eine Wirtschaftspolitik auf dem Tisch
die auf islamistischen docken und
basiert eines dieser Doktor ist zum
Beispiel das Zinsen etwas sehr böses
sind und auf diese Weise heizt Erdogan
die Inflation massiv an der Wert der
Lehrer ist zerstört in gewisser Weise
ist die Türkei immer mehr wie Russland
geworden ein Land zu dem Sie obwohl Sie
NATO Mitglied ist praktisch
uneingeschränkte Beziehungen unterhält
braucht ihr einen Beweis sie euch an 27
April 2023 Erdogan und Putin feiern die
Zusammenarbeit beim Bau des ersten
türkischen Atomkraftwerks tja
ironischerweise ist Erdogan aber in
einem ganz bestimmten Punkt vollkommen
und islamisch und zwar wenn es um den
eigenen Geldbeutel geht bzw den seiner
Amigos unter Erdogan grassierte die
Korruption z.B in der Bauwirtschaft die
sehr eng an die AKP gekoppelt ist
Bauvorschriften zum Beispiel bezüglich
Erdbebensicherheit wurden
massivst unterlaufen und das dicke Ende
dieser Misswirtschaft liest dann
schließlich nicht auf sich warten
allerdings war es mehr ein dickes Ende
für die Menschen in der Türkei nicht für
Erdogan denn trotz alldem hat er die
Wahlen erneut gewonnen und wie das
passieren konnte schauen wir uns jetzt
an
ein politisches Erdbeben
im Februar dieses Jahres wurde die
türkische Stadt gar sie Antep von einem
schrecklichen erdbebenheim gesucht bei
dem er als 55.000 Menschen ums Leben
kamen die ausbleibende Hilfe und der
katastrophale Umgang wäre Regierung mit
der Tragödie schienen die Tür für einen
politischen Wandel zu öffnen die
Wirtschaft liegt in Trümmern die AGP
Erdogans Partei hat ihre Reserven
aufgebraucht und ihre Versprechungen und
Ausgaben ändern ausgeweitet um ihr
klingenetzwerk zu stärken ich weiß nicht
wie das Land dem wirtschaftlichen
Zusammenbruch entgehen könnte darum
azimolo Wirtschaftswissenschaftler und m
it-professor außerdem hat sich der
größte Teil der Opposition unter einer
einzigen Kandidatur zusammengeschlossen
Thema war der große Favorit und doch hat
er verloren er unterlag Erdogan sowohl
im ersten als auch im zweiten Wahlgang
die Türken haben auf einen politischen
Führer Gesetz der die bürgerlichen
Freiheiten beschnitten eine
Wirtschaftskrise ausgelöst und sich mit
der NATO und der Europäischen Union
angelegt hat und das alles offenbar für
eine ganz klare Prämisse die Türkei zu
einer islamischen Großmarkt zu machen
erdogan hat eine ungezügelte
nationalistische Stimmung genährt die
ihm nun zum Sieg verholfen hat und hat
aufs Herz an wen erinnert uns diese
Strategie nur man könnte sagen dass
Erdogan in der Türkei zu einer Art Putin
geworden ist einst ein gemäßigter
Politiker mit einem Eifer für die
Erneuerung der Beziehung zum Besten ist
der heute fast zu einer Art Albtraum
geworden ein Verbündeter der unbequemer
ist als viele Feinde und der uns noch so
einige Kopfzerbrechen bereiten dürfte
aber dies werden wir noch ausgiebig in
Folge Videos behandeln vergesst also wie
gesagt nicht unseren Kanal zu abonnieren
und auch das Glöckchen zu aktivieren
damit ihr sie nicht verpasst bis dahin
würden wir gerne von euch wissen was
denkt ihr wie weit wird Erdogan gehen
hat er das Zeug zu einem absoluten
Monster zu mutieren wie Putin wird die
Türkei noch weiter auf die schiefe Bahn
der Autokratie geraten wird dieses Land
so eine Art Russland im Nahen Osten
werden wie immer sind auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem spannenden und
kontro sen Thema schon mächtig gespannt
ich hoffe dass euch dieses Video
gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht etwas
dabei gelernt habt falls ja gibt uns ein
Like und teilt es mit euren Freunden um
es auch mit Ihnen ausgewiebig zu
diskutieren natürlich freuen uns auch
wie gesagt jederzeit über eine Spende
von euch dieses Projekt weiterzuführen
den Link dazu findet ihr in der
Beschreibung unter dem Video macht's gut
und bis bald
[Musik]